ok 321 was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video war wo viel wir schon
jetzt auf den server meine damen und
herren ihr seht schon anmelden wir sind
auf eure alten zombie wargame obama als
wir alle drauf schon was sind das denn
für [ __ ] wo bist du denn ich bin
offen server wo bist du so bist du max
max wo bist du
wie kann ich denn woanders sein als du
wo bist du ich drücke auf f3 und sagt
mit einem koordinaten meine sind 51 42
53 35 alter warte ich muss mir erst mal
ganz kurz hier was machen eine
spitzhacke ich habe mich jetzt einfach
eine wand ja sagen jawohl du bist meine
koordinaten wollen doch in die gruppe
gepostet max ja aber ich kann ja jetzt
nicht die gruppe öffne ich muss nicken
warte ich muss mich grad weg haben
rom ein und ist jemand bei dir es sind
so viele leute gerade auf dem server ich
hätte nie gedacht dass welche nach
choina erwarten ist locker über mir
alter ich glaube ich kann einfach nur
nach oben geht sagte jetzt meine
koordinaten max okay ja sagt sie
400 690 ja 50325 ok ja wir waren doch
beieinander ich hatten die folge nicht
noch mal angeschaut wo wir uns aus
gelockt haben ich war einfach unten in
der höhle bleibt genau da wo du bist ich
kontrollieren ich habe mich gerade weg
hoch wie willst du erst mal
zusammenfinden
ja aber max dann kommen auch kommen ja
ich hab ich doch ich bin jetzt bei
moment 500
wie ist meine ich mein spitzhacke kaputt
mache ich denn hier so weit ich bin in
der höhle bist du schon oben
nee ich hab mich grad nach oben du
siehst das ankoppeln weg max okay ich
gehe jetzt an die oberfläche ja wir
müssen ja eher abbauen
wir haben uns beide unabhängig
voneinander quasi nach oben ja ok ayda
ist so schön angst dass oben der leute
sind bittet nicht die ganze zeit max ja
ich habe auch angst dass ihr welche
kommen aber man kann's nicht nun
springen gleichzeitig na ja das auf
jeden fall okay gut ja leute also noch
mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst wie sogar
zu viele leute geträumt sind max
übernahme das bin ich
dauert dann bist du oh mein gott oh mein
gott wo bist du denn ich sehe dich
warten es nicht mal ganz kurz
ok ich kommst du dich kommst du dir
bleibt da stehen max bleibt da stehen ja
ich war dachte ich okay
oh mein gott wir müssen endlich wieder
den folge unter der erde machen gerade
in der letzten minute meine koordinaten
wurden veröffentlicht das heißt ich habe
ein streik das seht ihr auch schon dem
titel das hat man mir geschrieben weil
ich wohl irgendwie aus versehen in der
ersten folge ich bin selber ein bisschen
peinlich aber man muss natürlich auf die
regeln achten
ich habe in der ersten folge leider
irgendwie 1 2 millisekunden von dem
gameplay rausgeschnitten ist nein
lukom nicht zu mir kommt nicht zu mir
[Musik]
auf keinen fall zu mir kommen ich komme
ich zu dem markt
alter hast du dich gegen von der band
gegraben marx alltag
ich hab ich auch viele leute total
darauf seien ein zu töten
ok luca ich bin jetzt unter der erde max
peter entkommen bitte ich will nicht
dass es vorbei ist mit uns ich will es
auch nicht mal mein herz pocht er war
direkt vor mir zum glück habe ich mit f5
geschaut ob er mich gesehen hat ich
dachte er hatte ich gesehen und ist oder
wie alter leute das ist wieder an
spannung pur ich sag euch diese folgen
hiervon waren sind die aller
spannendsten von uns glaubt ich weil wir
immer verfolgt werden von irgendwelchen
blödmännern ich er muss es gesehen haben
er muss es gesehen haben also mich hat
er auf jeden fall nicht gesehen bei mir
ist kein mensch ich habe mich auch
wieder ein bisschen in die erde ich bin
darauf 55 ich glaube mich gerade einfach
nur weiter ich glaube jetzt sogar falls
jemand meinen weg finden sollte graf ich
jetzt sogar so ein bisschen in die
saiten rein damit die leute denken okay
da ist da irgendwie her gelaufen aber
what the [ __ ] alter wie um 16 uhr
schlagartig der gesamte server voll war
junge es sind so sieben acht leute
geträumt nur weil unsere koordinaten
gezeigt leider war ich bin fasste lava
gefalle max alter fehlen
das ding ist ich habe jetzt gerade nicht
mal einen eine spitzhacke und das ding
ist wenn wir irgendwie auf den auf die
idee gekommen ist weil wir uns das
letzte mal schon mit eisen vor ihm
versteckt haben ich hab's halt gerade
wieder gemacht dann findet er mich
gleich junge nummer kurzum die story
eben zu beenden
wieso schreibt er heim weil er will dass
irgend jemand antwortet dass einnahmen
sieht
oh mein gott also noch mal ganz kurz um
die story zu beenden wir ich hab den
streik bekommen weil ich irgendwie
millisekunden an gameplay
rausgeschnitten habe und irgendwie wenn
man halt ein streikrecht werden halt die
koordinaten von einem veröffentlicht in
der gruppe und wir sind die koordinaten
wurden veröffentlicht um mitternacht
oder sohn der server war zu dem
zeitpunkt offline und max und ich habe
es halt gesagt okay am nächsten tag und
16 uhr wenn der server online macht wir
können direkt drauf und wir hätten jetzt
nie gedacht dass da leute wirklich auch
bis 16 uhr warten nur um uns hinterher
zu zäunen alter und jetzt haben es
trotzdem so viele leute gemacht
fakt bei minusgraden server ist voll
wegen uns was soll das es wurde gestern
total viele koordinaten gepostet
ach so das weißt gar nicht also nicht
nur wegen uns nein ich glaube nicht
also mir hat bei mir ist gerade in
sneakers in kryta explodiert ich konnte
halt nicht einknicken und deshalb konnte
ich nicht vermeiden dass er explodiert
aber ich glaube ich für mister mord
schon wieder entkommen es ist so
unbeschreiblich junge muri wenn du das
siehst ist so verdammt spannend luca wie
sollen wir jemals wieder zusammenfinden
in der nächsten folge sehen wir uns
einfach gegenseitig die koordinaten ich
bin gerade wieder unter der erde ich bin
gerade auf höhe 43 wieder nein ich nehme
wahr ob man erfährt gerufen
sebastian natürlich sie verhasst der
tote die toten rufen nach ok meine
spitzhacke ist gleich auch kaputt das
heißt ich muss dann auf jeden fall kurz
entschieden aber ich bin auf 40 und ich
sie irgendwo einnahmen also mit
sicherheit das braut sich halt jemand
gerade meinen weg zurück ist es so
unbeschreiblich krank es ist so eine
anspannung wir sind zwar nur unter der
erde aber diese tatsache dass zehn leute
oder noch mehr gerade auf dem server
sind und jeder gerade bei uns sein
könnte weil jeder meine koordinaten hat
luca das ding bei mir ist ich muss mir
jetzt eine spitzhacke machen uns
ansonsten komme ich hier niemals raus
bei mir ist es auch meine spitze
vielleicht auch kaputt alter schwede ist
es so fucking spannend ich bin ich
gerade dumm oder habe ich gerade lust am
morgen
was wir also es tut mir jetzt wirklich
leid ich will ich will ihn nicht nicht
beleidigen oder sowas aber es ist halt
so bitter ich war zwei mal buchstäblich
drei blöcke von ihm entfernt und bin ihm
jedes mal entkommen
marx ich hab mich gerade in irgendeiner
höhle eingebuddelt ich weiß nicht ob ich
die weiterlaufen soll oder ob ich mich
im kreis gebildet habe sag mir mal
deinen cordes hatte ich muss mir eben
eine spitzhacke machen oh mein gott
alte tobi und dehne auch noch okay ich
glaube hier slawen kundennähe das
leuchtet hier so also allmählich lang zu
aber auch mal mit leuten hier auf dem
server es ist nicht wahr leute der ganze
server ist voll
es ist also das heißt der ganze sind
natürlich locker noch mehr leute die
drauf zahlen können aber es ist nur noch
krass gerade ich frag mich die ganze
zeit ob ich nicht man wagen soll an die
höhe zu allen in die höhe zu bauen
ich weiß bleibt auch nicht so mysteriös
ausgeleuchtet hier als wäre hier
irgendwo lava bei mir also ich würde
sagen luca okay ist es vorbei ich würde
sagen okay es war von offen
das einzige was ich jetzt lohnt für uns
beide wir müssen wieder zusammenfinden
allein haben wir schon mal gar keine
chance ist dass wir an die erdoberfläche
gehen ja wirklich nicht ob mir das nicht
lieber in der nächsten folge machen
sollten
oder noch besser ist wenn wir uns
unterirdisch finden sagt mir mal noch
mal seine koordinaten meine koordinaten
530 h43 auf der höhe bleibe ich auch
okay und 270
270 okay bei mir sind es 400 die letzte
koordinate sonst sind wir uns relativ
nah 400 ja dann kommen uns entgegen
laufen ja also bei mir sind die
koordinaten 526 und 412 ich kommen jetzt
erst mal auf der höhe
wie war dein letztes koordinaten noch
mal 270 meine letzte war 270 jahre ok
also ich probiere mich mal in deine
richtung zu bauen
okay das will was hast du bei der ersten
koordinate 500 bis 530 bleibt dann lass
mal 515 gehen erstmal auf die erste
koordinate japan auf 500 ich gehe eher
auf der anderen entgegen okay machen wir
so so schief bauen
ich hoffe nur dass wir das hinkriegen
bisschen bis sie voll gezeichnet ich
hatte echt gedacht die wir sind tot als
die ganzen namen gewinnen wir hatten
gedacht okay allerhöchstens joint und
vielleicht ein team nach okay okay okay
ich habe mich in den sehr eingegraben
aber seewasser sie aber ich versuche
mich drum rum zu graben dabei haben auf
jeden fall schon mal dort wo wir raus
können max es geht so langsam wie mama
die koordinaten zu dass die leute nicht
irgendwie sehen können wo ich durch bin
ich habe den job meines lebens gab beim
ist er gerade dafür kämpfen rennen war
der neben dir
er war direkt neben mir ja also er hat
mich gesehen es war nicht mal ein block
zwischen uns was und die sind vor allem
schon forint also wir sind auch für iron
aber junge andere finden zwei diamanten
und alles anders aber bei uns ist
einfach die größte spannung glaube
waffenbesitz wegzulaufen schaffen wird
nicht bei mir ist auch gerade wasser
rein gekommen
wow alter was geht ab es ist einfach
alles spannend irgendwie da waren gerade
im moment voll
max welche koordinaten ich glaub ich bin
beim gleichen see bei denen du auch bist
ich bin bei ich habe erste koordinate
520 und die letzte 305 ich glaube wir
können weit im gleichen design optisch
muss an die oberfläche schwimmen max ich
bin nicht in dem see bleibt ohne halter
schweden ein ich darf jetzt nicht
ersticken
ok weiter nach unten
ja ich muss ja irgendwie nach oben
kommen jetzt da wird dir auch nichts zu
rütteln
ok ich muss jetzt anfangen rotem fleisch
zu essen damit ich regeneriere ich habe
mir auch kein essen mehr
max ich komm -rat extra in eine
koordinaten die ich gerade mich die
ganze zeit nur unter der erde her
ich bin über der erde und mir ist so
heiß mehr normal aber es ist schon voll
war mit meiner wohnung alter schwede ich
bin jetzt überirdisch überirdisch ja
welche koordinaten 480 305 480 60 380
max um mich rum passiert irgendwas
probelauf bitte zu 513 313 max 113 313
muss dann aufhören zu ich muss anfangen
zu sprinten weil die in fernost maxi ist
irgendwer
okay okay ich probier zu kommen ich
probiere gekommen hier beißt ihnen wer
ab was von seinem essen ja dann baute
ich hoch oder runter nicht nicht
stehenbleiben auf keinen fall stehen bei
dem auch irgendwie
muss irgendwie an essen kommen marx lauf
hierhin ich bin unterwegs man wie viel
anspannung wo ich habe irgendwas gehört
wie war es nochmal 513 520 513 5 513 520
503 10 320 pro junge ich habe kein gutes
gefühl bei der folge ich auch nicht das
ding ist ich muss bald essen finden
sonst sterbe ich
ich kann jetzt bald nicht mehr sprinten
wie weit kannst du dennoch weg sein
ich bin nicht gut darin nach koordinaten
zu laufen ok ich kann jetzt nicht mehr
sprint ich muss jetzt erst finden luca
bei mir um mich herum explodiert
irgendwas hier sind leute ich glaub dir
es ja aber ich war die klassen ab und
nahmen ich sehe da nahmen überall was
mache ich habe keine ahnung
wir werden sie sind bei mir sind bei mir
locker und ich wurde gekickt und auch
geklickt alter ich weiß nicht was wir
jetzt machen sollen
bei der bank ausgemacht halbfertig bei
mir sind überall leute vor mir direkt
auf einem offenen feld sind mario mister
morgen alter leute ich würde sagen wir
werden erstmal die folge ob wir die
nächste folge überleben seht ihr in der
nächsten last light da wenn es euch
gefallen hat